though lydia is usually very uptight
and refrains from getting her hands
dirty lydia is by far
one of the most evil characters within
the breaking bad universe
from her constant drive to wipe out
everyone who could even pose the
slightest of threats
to her deceptive innocent face lydia
is the definition of deceiving looks but
throughout her laundry list of misdeeds
how much money does lydia even make
well starting off with her cushy
corporate job
lydia is at the top of the ladder at
magical electromotive
serving as a head of logistics to
estimate how much money she exactly gets
paid from madrigal
we have to take a look at how big of a
corporation magical is
in season 3 episode 9 of better call
saul
lydia reveals to mike that matrigo has
000 employees and we know that madrigal
is involved in many businesses
but the main two are the manufacturing
of industrial equipment
and global shipping so magical
electromotive
is essentially a giant industrial
manufacturer and shipping company
with over a hundred thousand employees
when you think of a real-life magical
one of the first companies that come to
mind is ge or general electric
ge was actually one of the largest
companies in the world
five to ten years ago but for quite a
while now
they've actually been on a downward
trend so they wouldn't actually be that
good of a comparison
a similar company that's actually doing
very well on the other hand
is honeywell honeywell has a very
similar employee count to magical
at 110 000 employees and
they have a market cap of right over 100
billion dollars
so we'll say that matrigo was also
roughly a 100 billion dollar company
taking a look at honeywell's executives
the ceo makes about 20 million dollars
per year
while the other executives make between
six and eight million dollars per year
now lydia isn't technically a top-level
executive
as she doesn't hold a vice president or
chief level position
she is more of a regional executive at
the time we see her
as for her duties lydia reveals that she
handles eight freight terminals across
the southwest
with weekly operating expenses of 800
000 to 1 million dollars
even with weekly expenses of 800 grand
lydia oversees a minimum
of 41.6 million worth of operations
annually
as a result it's no doubt that lydia
makes at least a couple of million
dollars per year from her work
assuming she makes 5 of what she
oversees lydia will be pulling in about
two million dollars per year
this makes sense as it's far greater
than the average manager or director
who would put roughly one hundred to two
hundred thousand dollars a year
but at the same time it follows several
million dollars short
from what top level executives earn
considering this
i'm really not sure why lydia dipped
into the dark side
as she was already earning millions per
year plus
it was just a matter of time before she
would be promoted to a top-level
executive
earning several million per year but
anyways as for how long lydia has been
working in this position
we see that lydia is already the head of
logistics in season 3 of better call
saul
which takes place at the end of 2003
considering that she doesn't die until
september of 2010
lydia is at least ahead of logistics for
seven years if she's not promoted during
that time frame
assuming she became head of logistics
three years before meeting mike
lydia would have held this position for
about 10 years
as for her job before becoming the head
of logistics she was likely a high level
senior director within the company
earning a few hundred thousand dollars a
year but we wouldn't even consider that
as at least level it only has a minimal
impact
plus we want to keep the estimate
conservative so
from her corporate job lydia pulls in a
solid 20 million
over 10 years as for her journey in the
underworld
though she knows gus for quite a while
she doesn't actually start profiting
from the operation
until the super lab is up and running
starting with the super lab construction
itself
the entire lab is estimated cost about 8
million dollars
however most of this probably went
towards the construction itself
as opposed to industrial equipment so
lydia
likely didn't profit too much selling
equipment for gus's lab
her main source of income from guz is
from selling him chemicals
and this does add up to quite a bit
despite the lab only being up for six
months
in the how much does gus spring make
video we estimate that gus pays about 20
to his chemical producers but he does
have multiple sources
assuming that it's a 50 50 split between
magical and choice chemical company
peter and lydia would get 10 of the
total revenue again
splitting it in half between peter and
lydia lydia would get approximately five
percent of the total revenue
at 200 pounds a week at 2 500 per ounce
for 24 weeks
lydia would receive a cool 9.6 million
dollars in just 6 months
which is a rate that's 10 times faster
than a corporate job
after gus's empire crumbles to the hands
of walter lydia helps baldr pull off the
methylamine heist
from how much mike and jesse sell off
their shares of the methylamine for
we know that they stole roughly 15
million worth of methylamine
now lydia should get a portion of this
as she was the one who enabled the whole
operation to run smoothly however it
doesn't seem like terms were ever
settled or that lydia was ever paid out
for the heist itself
mike did spare her life so i think she
accepted that as a payment
though it doesn't seem like she got any
money from the heist itself
we do know that lydia was paid for
providing wall's product and then later
jesse's product to czech republic
in season 5 episode 8 lydia reveals that
she plans to start with 10 pounds a week
and then scale up to 25 pounds per week
meaning 1 million
revenue per week she also thinks that a
30 share of the revenue is fair
for international services assuming that
half of her share went towards paying
for any more she had to pay in the
distribution network
or dealers in the czech republic lydia
would profit 15
of the total revenue or 150 000 per week
lydia does work with waldrop for a bit
of time but
most of her business in the czech
republic is fulfilled by uncle jack
using jessie
given that lydia makes this deal with
walter in the last episode of season 5a
she basically has the entirety of season
5b to profit from her network
given that season 5b covers between
march and september 2010
this gives lydia right about 6 months to
work with todd
subtracting 2 weeks for any sort of
production issues lydia would profit 150
per week for 24 weeks amount to 3.6
million dollars
adding this 3.6 million to the 9.6
million she made with guzz
lydia profited a total of 13.2 million
dollars from her shady dealings
along with their corporate gig lydia
made a total of 33.2 million dollars
or write about 30 million dollars at the
end of the day
lydia was making 5 to 10 times more than
her corporate job per year
with their underground dealings but
really lydia should have just stepped
out when she could
after gus's death as the extra risk was
simply not worth it
as it's not like she needed money
anyways furthermore
it was just a matter of time until
someone above her retired or switched
companies
at which point she could have become a
top-level executive making several
million per year
completely legally moreover given her
high intellect and young age
she could have easily invested this
money into various reliable investments
without having to worry about the
security of her life or getting put
behind bars
and by the time she retires she could
have had hundreds of millions of dollars
just for her
and her daughter but as we already know
lydia let a little short-term gains
overshadow her long-term success do you
guys think lydia should have just
started a cushy corporate job
make sure to comment that down below
also if you guys like the depth of the
analysis then make sure to drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari i'll see you guys on the next
one